you've been effectively driven out of
your own University as an undergraduate
standing up against racism indeed these
people had flipped the script and said
if you don't sign up for our racism
you're a racist to the extent that I am
recognized it is typically as a result
of the meltdown at Evergreen and my
stance is Evergreen State called the
Evergreen State College in Olympia
Washington where I taught for 14 years
along with my wife Heather huiying who
taught there for 15 years we faced a mob
of people who accused me of racism and
these were students they were students I
had never met and the event was so
colorful and eventually when the world
caught on to the fact that the
protesters who became rioters had
uploaded footage to the net and so the
whole event could effectively be seen
from their perspective it raised
interest in some other quadrants so for
example I ended up on Joe Rogan's
program which is the place I'm probably
most recognized from and you know the my
first appearance there we talked about
the evergreen situation and anyway
that's that's the the bulk of how people
know me all right so you were a
biologist teaching at a relatively
obscure college that had previously been
known for social activism and I didn't
love your introduction because when you
say well the students accused me of
racism that leaves sort of a weird
question like why was he accused of
racism let me solve the puzzle just
immediately maybe you can't do this
because that was the closest we'd seen
to a Maoist takeover inside of the
United States of America ever like it
was a case of mass insanity and the
videos showed it to be mass insanity and
unless you had been indoctrinated to
believe that maoism of some form Maoist
re-education was normal the rest of the
world said oMG what the heck is going on
at this completely and say it
just like one of these college craziness
pieces this is really an episode of
broad institutional madness that was
localized there and I just I want to
take it to be self-evident because it is
self-evident the video exists and if you
took the people who were trying to
pretend that you were a racist in their
own terms that was sufficient - it was
like the unreliable narrator they were
they were debunking themselves in the
eyes of everyone who hadn't come under
the spell of this particular kind of
madness well there's a little little
more to it in the sense that they were
entirely unprepared for a white guy
willing to say no I'm simply not a
racist and it just didn't occur to them
that that was going to happen and it
didn't occur to them that my own
students weren't going to flee to their
side at the point that they leveled
their accusation because those things
would have been normal in this
environment but in my case I grew up in
a home there were plenty of flaws in
that home as you know but one of the
places I don't think it was flawed was
that it was very clear-headed about
issues of inequality race justice and so
I I really have the sense that it's
these issues were really not new to me
and I had a long history at the college
lots of students of color you're
explaining too much I don't mean to be
rude about it but they were just crazy
they were crazy but my point is the
accusation is in and of itself so
powerful in modern circumstances that
people the idea of standing up to it
doesn't occur to most people and the
fact is I was not well enough positioned
the thing descended into madness it
descended into literal anarchy with
armed students roving the campus the
same mob was looking for me
searching car-to-car for example is a
very dangerous situation so amazing bill
that's but
but what I'm getting at is I checked
with myself and did not feel vulnerable
to this accusation I felt most people
could not endure it but I was in a
position to and in an odd way you've
been effectively driven out of your own
University as an undergraduate standing
up against racism indeed these people
had flipped the script and said if you
don't sign up for our racism you're a
racist yeah they didn't I don't you know
here's the thing I have two documents
that I've studied that have a lot of
longevity to them one begins with we
hold these truths to be self-evident and
the other one begins with in the
beginning and I think we've made a huge
mistake taking this as an argument
it's a non-serious position held by
morons and idiots or people who have
been indoctrinated and infected with an
idea that there is something left-wing
about being a racist I'm not interested
in and I also think that it's really
important to stop giving these people
their due like it's really important to
exclude them from the conversation
because if you have to have a three-day
symposium as to whether or not racism
can be redefined in a way that makes it
impossible for certain people to be
racist but impossible for other people
not to be racist there's just no point
there just it just needs to be thrown in
the garbage because it just it's a
suicide idea that wastes everyone's time
and plunges the world into stupidity
madness and hatred well you and I are in
total agreement about the necessity to
shut the bad actors rate out of the the
conversation I do have some concern
about a large number of people who fall
into one of two camps they're either
confused or they suffer from so much
cowardice that they will sign up for
ideas that they ought to know are wrong
yeah but I think you're not getting the
message we've made a huge mistake and I
refuse to spend time because these
people have decided that this is a text
that we should pay that they have a
serious point it's a non serious point
it's a terrifying
Raonic non-serious point that you can
redefine racism to be anti racism and
anti racism to be racist nobody knows
this better than me free
[Music]
[Music]